[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
June 21st I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
many companies are taking steps to
address increased frustration and low
morale among workers Wall Street Journal
reporter Russell Adams joins us so
Russell what has caused employees to be
unhappy at work the main thing is that
the pandemic took a toll on worker
morale both in service jobs like
restaurant workers and hotel workers and
also among white-collar employees who
work in an office every day I think in
the former category and the service jobs
they were woefully understaffed and so
workers were asked to do a lot more than
they normally do we're asked to work
longer hours and more stringent
schedules and that really weighed
heavily and then on the office worker
side because most of us went home for a
while the boundaries between our
professional and personal lives got
increasingly blurred and people were
asked to basically be on call at
whatever job they do all the time okay
so let's look at some ways that
companies are trying to improve
employees experiences something that
frustrates many workers whether they're
in the office or working remotely are
additions to their daily calendar that
slow down the work day oftentimes the
culprit is the dreaded meeting how are
companies addressing that another
byproduct of the pandemic is that we got
a lot more meetings on our calendars by
one measure the amount of hours that the
average worker spends in a meeting
almost triple during that period of time
and I think that as we got back to a
normal schedule we kind of held on to
way too many of those meetings that were
unnecessary now that a lot of us were
back together in the office and some
companies have taken a hard look at this
and really found that it really cuts
into productivity and wastes a lot of
time one company that we focused on is
Shopify they've taken a really hard look
at meetings and they found that they
were able to delete 12 000 events and
that added up to 95 000 total hours
saved that's a lot of time back in
people's schedule that's a lot of time
yes are these steps being taken solely
to appease workers No in fact a lot of
companies are doing these things with an
eye not just to improve the quality of
life for workers at work but also to
boost productivity and efficiency we're
seeing broadly A Renewed focus on
efficiency or as you know Mark
Zuckerberg called it the year of
efficiency and I think a lot of
Executives have have sort of taken that
and run with it you mentioned
restaurants a moment ago and those
companies in particular have dealt with
a severe labor shortage as they emerged
from the pandemic how they handled that
that's been sort of a vicious cycle they
had a labor shorter that emanated from
the pandemic and then they asked more
and more of the workers that did stay
and they became increasingly miserable
and left and so you had this cycle where
restaurant workers became increasingly
stretched and miserable and so some of
that labor shortage has eased recently
but it's still acute and what we've seen
is some restaurant operators have taken
a hard look at how these workers spend
their days one in particular is Chili's
which did sort of a deep dive into how
it does everything and the amount of
time that workers spent on things that
are really unnecessary and at Chili's
it's really interesting the the CEO
found that there was this thing that
workers in the restaurant had to do
every day where they count and bag
shrimp which was totally unnecessary and
that by eliminating that task it saved 6
million in labor costs another thing
they did is that because of the the
worker shortage they cut down on busers
and that made the jobs of servers that
much more difficult and so they've added
hours to buser's schedules which is ease
the load on servers as well and then
they also streamline the menu offerings
Chili's has long had a very expansive
menu which taxed the kitchen and so they
streamline some of the items that were
more labor intensive or less popular and
customers don't always like that but
it's been well received in the kitchens
and you might think that giving raises
or financial incentives might be enough
to appease workers but in a lot of cases
it really isn't enough to keep workers
happy what if some companies done
instead we've seen that across several
Industries is that companies have raised
pay you know with inflation but they
have found that job satisfaction didn't
really improve markedly when they took
those steps and they had to take a
harder look at the nature of a lot of
these jobs and what they could do to
make make them more sort of Humane and
livable so one example we've seen with
Uber the CEO spent some time undercover
as a driver to really look at what life
was like for a driver and all of the
sort of daily annoyances that they face
and found that the job was full of those
annoyances that you know he took a hard
look at and tried to figure out what he
could do to improve it they seem kind of
small but the drivers traditionally had
to accept a job before they knew what
the destination was which meant that
they got stuck going to a place where
they knew they couldn't find a pickup to
take them back to where they were before
it was a real annoyance for them and so
he streamlined that process in another
industry British Airways the company
outfitted Crews with brand new outfits
that are more weather resistant it's a
really difficult job a lot of turnovers
similar to the restaurant industry
you know the weather is tough the hours
are long it's uncomfortable you're in
the belly of a plane pulling out bags
and that Airline says that workers are
thrilled with the new outfits which have
made a big difference another company
has introduced revamped break rooms for
baggage handlers with TVs and lockers
and other things that they said have
gone a long way at the operator of
Frankfurt airport now gives employees
ice cream on the tarmac which is a small
thing but I can make anybody's day
better right exactly I think we should
all have that so what else have
companies done one of the companies that
we've taken a close look at which is
really interesting is a t
they took a real close look at how
workers spend their day and they
identified more than 160 tasks that they
realized they could either streamline or
eliminate and save a lot of time from
workers schedules so they looked at
things like traditionally if an employee
had a retirement or service anniversary
party whoever organized the party had to
enter every attendee's name into the
system for the expense reports and at T
calculated that that was costing workers
28 500 hours a year oh wow and so it
eliminated that requirement and many
like it which they say is having a big
difference uh as far as efficiency and
productivity so whether it's the expense
reports or counting shrimp or
eliminating meetings these really do add
up to enormous blocks of time oh yeah so
how have employees responded has morale
improved anecdotally they've responded
very well to it the baggage handlers are
saying that life has significantly
improved again the power of ice cream
the power of ice cream exactly at A T
we've heard from some workers that you
know taking out those daily annoyances
the amount of time spent on mundane
annoying tasks has really really
improved their lives so generally it's
been well received that's Wall Street
Journal reporter Russell Adams and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you